Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Vi chiedo di chiudere gli occhi.
Ora non vedete più niente
di ciò che vi circonda.
Sempre con gli occhi chiusi,
vi chiedo di stare in silenzio
per una frazione di secondo.
Ecco: ora non vedete e non sentite,
eppure esistite ancora.
Adesso vi chiedo una terza cosa:
provate a sentire la sensazione
che vi arriva dallo stare seduti,
appoggiando la vostra schiena sulla sedia.
Oppure quando toccate,
con i vostri piedi, a terra.
Adesso, provate a non sentire
questa sensazione.
Difficile, eh?
Forse è anche impossibile,
perché la sensazione del tocco
è ciò che vi riporta continuamente
a voi stessi, alla vostra esistenza.
Ora potete aprire gli occhi.
Se pensiamo al tocco,
dobbiamo sapere che si sviluppa
a partire dalle primissime ore
di vita, già nell'utero;
ed è il primo senso che si sviluppa.
Se andiamo a pensare, quindi,
a quanto è importante
questa sensazione del tocco,
dobbiamo andare indietro in molti anni,
quando è stato fatto un esperimento
in cui si è voluto proprio domandarsi
quanto è importante il senso del tocco.
E hanno preso queste
scimmiette appena nate,
le hanno messe dentro una gabbietta.
All'interno c'erano due scimmie di ferro:
una produceva il latte,
e l'altra era semplicemente
ricoperta da un peluche.
Quello che hanno fatto le scimmiette,
tutte le scimmiette
che sono state testate,
era andarsi a prendere il latte
della scimmia che produceva il latte
e poi andare a stare
il resto della giornata
accovacciati sulla scimmietta
ricoperta di peluche.
Questo per dire cosa?
Che la sensazione
della protezione, e del calore,
è ciò che è talmente importante
da essere un bisogno primario,
al pari del mangiare.
E così importante che, addirittura,
alcuni ricercatori hanno cercato
di studiare le cellule del tocco,
e hanno trovato che esistono
delle cellule particolari,
che si chiamano CTX cells,
cellule tattili,
che si attivano in modo particolare
per una sensazione
che è lenta, di tocco lento,
e all'interno abbastanza esteso,
e con una superficie con una temperatura
superiore ai 30 gradi.
Il tocco umano: questo tocco
viene chiamato “tocco affettivo”.
Allora, per farvi capire meglio,
il nostro sistema nervoso risponde -
i segnali del sistema nervoso rispondono
a una velocità di 400 chilometri orari,
prima di arrivare al cervello.
Le cellule, invece,
che rispondono a questo tocco lento
viaggiano a una velocità
di due chilometri orari,
perché arrivano a un'altra
parte del cervello.
Quella parte - quindi,
diversamente dai segnali
che arrivano alla corteccia
somatosensoriale,
che ci dice che cosa stiamo toccando,
dove, per quanto tempo,
con che intensità -
il tocco lento passa
attraverso le emozioni
che ci dicono che cosa proviamo
quando veniamo toccati.
Quindi è estremamente importante,
perché questo tocco affettivo
ci riporta a chi siamo,
quello che siamo in relazione
a ciò che ci circonda.
Oltre a questa area, che si chiama
giro insulare posteriore,
quello che succede è che noi attiviamo
anche un'altra area specifica,
che viene definita giro angolare.
Il giro angolare è interessante,
perché è un'area che si attiva
in tante funzioni,
come per esempio estrapolare
le informazioni
che provengono dalle parole,
oppure recuperare le informazioni
che sono state depositate in memoria;
o ancora, quando dobbiamo relazionare
con le altre persone.
Ma in modo particolare, il giro angolare
fa parte di un network
che viene definito Default Mode Network,
ed è un network che si attiva
ogni qualvolta pensiamo a noi stessi,
e ogni qualvolta agiamo in modo creativo.
Cosa vuol dire questo?
Che nel momento in cui noi andiamo
a stimolare questo giro angolare,
che cosa succede?
Questo è quello che hanno
trovato i ricercatori:
che si prova quella
sensazione extracorporea,
come se il nostro sé mentale
sorvolasse il nostro sé fisico,
il nostro corpo fisico.
Quindi, il tocco affettivo
ci riporta continuamente a noi stessi,
a ciò che siamo attraverso le emozioni,
cioè esseri umani.
L'aspetto importante
è che ci sono anche delle ricerche
che hanno dimostrato
che il tocco affettivo
è implicato nella costituzione
del programma epigenetico.
Cerco di farvi capire.
All'interno del nucleo
delle nostre cellule,
si trova il DNA.
Il DNA è fatto di due filamenti
in cui sono scritte le informazioni
che servono per produrre le proteine,
che sono gli elementi base
di qualsiasi organismo.
Ora, se facciamo finta
che questo DNA sia un libro di ricette,
all'interno del libro di ricette
immaginate dei segnalibro.
Questi segnalibro ci danno indicazioni
di quali ricette vogliamo fare,
ovvero quali geni verranno trasmessi.
Questo vuol dire ancora di più, però,
perché quando noi sviluppiamo -
quand'è che sviluppiamo questi segnalibri?
In realtà, li incominciamo a sviluppare
quando siamo nell'utero,
attraverso l'interazione
con l'ambiente, lo sviluppo fetale;
ma non solo, anche quando nasciamo,
in relazione a ciò che mangiamo,
ciò che respiriamo,
alle esperienze traumatiche
o alle esperienze positive
che noi viviamo.
Questi aspetti epigenetici si tramandano
di generazione in generazione,
da genitore a figlio.
E secondo alcune intuizioni, recenti,
dell’epigenetica comportamentale,
le esperienze traumatiche
che noi abbiamo vissute
nel nostro passato,
o che hanno vissuto i nostri antenati,
si sono come - hanno creato
delle cicatrici molecolari nel DNA,
i nostri segnalibri.
Queste cicatrici molecolari si attaccano
sull'impalcatura della nostra
struttura genetica.
Questo vuol dire che noi
abbiamo ereditato dai nostri avi
non solo il naso grande,
come la mia nonna,
o gli occhi scuri;
ma abbiamo anche ereditato
la tendenza, ad esempio,
a entrare in depressione
se i nostri antenati hanno vissuto
degli stati di negligenza,
durante la loro primissima infanzia.
Questo è importante,
perché il tocco affettivo
diventa l'aspetto, invece,
che può dare quelle espressioni
non negative, ma positive, di relazione
che poi noi trasmetteremo ai nostri figli.
Se nasciamo ciechi,
riusciamo a svilupparci tranquillamente,
riusciamo ad avere una mente creativa;
se nasciamo sordi, altrettanto.
Ma se nasciamo con la capacità
di rilevare la sensazione tattile,
ma non veniamo toccati,
non veniamo toccati in modo affettivo,
noi non ci svilupperemo
come gli altri bambini.
Noi perché sappiamo queste cose?
Ci sono state delle situazioni,
per esempio in Romania,
sotto il Governo - la dittatura,
direi - di Ceausescu,
dove i bambini erano negli orfanotrofi
e venivano privati totalmente
del contatto con le altre persone.
Non venivano abbracciati,
non venivano accarezzati:
venivano solo nutriti.
Be’, questi bambini hanno riportato
dei deficit a livello psicologico,
disturbi neuropsichiatrici,
deficit anche a livello fisico.
Ma la cosa interessante
è che se si poteva intervenire -
quindi quando questi bambini
sono usciti dagli orfanotrofi,
e sono stati adottati -
ecco: quei bambini a cui erano state fatte
delle stimolazioni a livello tattile,
anche solo per mezz'ora al giorno,
erano in grado di recuperare
al pari degli altri;
ma solo, esclusivamente,
se ricevevano questo intervento
entro il primo anno di vita.
Questo per dire che la tempistica,
il tempismo, quando intervenire -
più precocemente si interviene, meglio è,
perché possiamo in effetti
risolvere delle situazioni.
Quindi, io credo che l'abbraccio,
l'avere la possibilità di essere toccati,
è ciò che ci riporta
continuamente a noi stessi,
è ciò che ci fa sentire
quello che noi siamo: esseri umani.
Allora ci sono altre tecniche,
come per esempio la risonanza magnetica,
perché sorge la domanda: “Ma chi siamo?”.
La risonanza magnetica -
attraverso questi studi,
si è potuto visualizzare
che ci sono delle aree,
all'interno del nostro cervello,
che si attivano prevalentemente
quando pensiamo a noi stessi.
Sono state fatte delle ricerche
su quanto delle persone
che dichiarano di essere sole,
e di vivere un profondo
stato di solitudine,
quando gli viene chiesto di pensare
alle persone che possono avere vicino,
persone che non conoscono,
queste aree cerebrali del sé
si attivano molto meno.
Questo per dire cosa?
Che quando siamo soli, ciò che viene meno
non è la relazione con l'altro -
ovvero, è anche quella:
ma in primis, è la relazione
con noi stessi, l'idea di noi stessi.
Se pensiamo a delle
situazioni di solitudine,
o alle incapacità di relazionarsi
con le altre persone,
come per esempio nel caso dell'autismo,
intervenire su questa dimensione
attraverso delle stimolazioni
relative al sé corporeo,
vuol dire lavorare sullo sviluppo.
E il tocco affettivo è la strada
che ci porta a questa risoluzione.
Quindi, dobbiamo ricordare
questa parola: tocco.
Senza un tocco, noi non possiamo
relazionare con gli altri.
Così come, però, senza un contatto
noi non esistiamo.